[Musique]
cérémonie religieuse à la mémoire donc
de deux personnes qui étaient très
impliqués dans le projet grâce à notre
guide qui est du village
il a demandé à donc trois personnes
religieuses de fer d'organiser cette
cérémonie pour avoir un temps de
spiritualité dans le temple du village
qui avait été complètement détruits
lors du tremblement terre 2015 et donc
on a pu faire également une offrande
pour montrer que l'on était attentif à
leurs histoires leurs suivants
j'ai moi même
10 juillet
[Musique]
pour les bouddhistes l'une des croyances
et que lorsqu'une personne meurt pendant
49 jours à partir du moment où elles ont
été cédées le corner et l'esprit se
détache du corps
et cette conscience restera dans les
rendements dans quarante ans
après ses 49 joueurs les us qui sera
prêt pour une autre ville et tout sera
allumé de nouveau
[Musique]
après ta mort tu as conscience n'a plus
aucune lumière 17 12 ici c'est une
source de lumière pour trouver ton
propre chemin c'est très apaisant et je
suis très heureuse d'avoir participé à
ça parce que ça m'a apaisé tout mon âme
j'aimerais beaucoup que soit la réalité
parce que
bah on sait pas si cela après la mort en
fait personne ne sait ce qui se passera
après la mort mais je trouve que c'est
très sage et très une belle façon de
penser à une très belle phrase en
français je trouve que c'est une
religion
qui très sage et
c'est pas du tout pareil que les
religions qu'on a à la réunion comme
chrétiens ou musulmans
[Musique]